research lead I online is a little bit
like opening Pandora's box you type in
what's the best diet for losing weight
building muscle into Google and you're
in for a surprise there's a lot of very
strong opinions on this subject many of
them completely contrasting and there's
literally no way of finding out which is
the correct one you've got people who
say a calorie is a calorie just lower
your calories the if y if ym if it fits
in your macros crowd then you've got the
ones saying you should cut your carbs
out or just the slow carbs the slow carb
diet or the no carb diet you have the
Paleo diet saying we should try new
things a lot closer to what we would
have eaten in the wilds you have people
saying you should do carb backloading or
intermittent fasting and all these
people they hate each other
with a passion and then you're thinking
where on earth do I start and then you
look at the studies online to see what
the actual science says and even that
contradicts itself you've got studies
that prove cutting carbs is the best way
to lose weight and you've got studies
saying that it makes no difference so
what on earth do you do I'm gonna
demystify it a little bit and give my
point of view in it of course it's just
one point of view but I think it's one
that a lot of the you know general
public could follow without having to
get too bogged down with science getting
involved in heated arguments etc
so the first thing I want to say the
general approach I take is just keep it
simple stupid you don't need to cut a
specific food group have your diet you
don't need to do some kind of elaborate
you can program where you're not eating
between this hour on this arrow you're
only eating this type of food between
this hour or you're getting into a
ketonic state point is whilst all that
might work and it might be great you
don't need to do it to get into good
shape in order to lose weight if you
watch interviews with any celebrity like
Hugh Jackman although he does do
intermittent fasting ironically or you
know for I remember his name or Chris
Evans
because heme work is or you know any
actor who's you know ripped and lean and
muscular they'll tell you that pretty
much what they ate was lots of chicken
and lots of rice pretty straight forward
to reading a lean protein fill the
muscle and keeping everything lean
including so that you don't add on too
much fat that's called eating clean and
basically avoid cake avoid chocolates
avoid crisps all the things you just
know about for you and at the same time
eat a few fewer calories how few
calories should you eat fewer than you
eating now and that's it it's that
simple because basically if you're the
weight you are now and you're eating the
calories that you're eating now that
means that the lifestyle and the food
you're eating a rich kind of equilibrium
if you're not gaining or losing weight
that means you've reached a kind of
equilibrium a kind of happy medium where
you're eating the right amount of
calories that you need to maintain the
usual weight so if you reduce your
calories at all or if you increase your
activity at all you're gonna upset this
balance in the positive way and you've
again going to burn a little bit of fat
so you're there's no magic number just a
little bit less than you are that's why
I would say nobody needs to be counting
calories because not only is incredibly
inaccurate and you're never gonna get
very accurate figure at the end of the
day but also it's just miserable and
it's unnecessary
because as long as you eating the less
than I'm eating now that's fine and does
the type of calorie matter yes to an
extent obviously you can lose weight by
just eating Donuts if you only ate one
doughnut today you would lose weight but
you'd also probably die it's not worth
it you need to be getting your nutrients
I'm going to talk a lot more on that in
a moment but also at the same time some
food some calories
will affect your waking differently than
others protein is less likely to be
stored as fat and fat is actually less
like to spike your blood sugar this is
what the low-carb people are saying and
it is true you fuel carbs you will find
that you have less of a kind of spiking
your insulin because fact releases that
the energy slower than the carbs do even
though that has more calories at the
same time a lot of the rubbish that we
eat our carbs you know the crisps the
cakes these all the fast carbs if you
cut those out your diet you'll find
pretty quickly that you're left with a
lot more wholesome whole food that
releases energy more slowly so so far
it's pretty simple you want to be eating
less and you want to be paying the right
things out of your diet just need
smaller portions than you were before if
you want to lose weight and at the same
time just cut more of the carbs the fat
carbs in particular and the other
nonsense please don't cut all your carbs
today because you do need them for
energy and your crash and you won't get
a workout if you don't have a car yes
you do get energy from fat like this so
really think you can get ketones from
you know certain types of fasting or
from coconut oil which everyone loves
and I love is great but that fuels the
glial cells of the brain the white
matter more than the gray matter the
neurons there's no point getting into it
but we eat all the things we eat for a
reason don't just you know say oh I'm
not gonna make is hopefully Greek
doesn't no need okay some are a little
bit better than others if you have
specific targets in mind they all have
their roles so they don't go nuts just
cut them down a little bit I reduce my
carbs the easiest way I know how which
is by not eating them at lunch
that's one meal fewer carbs and then for
dinner we will eat vegetables fruits but
we try and cut out things like potatoes
at the moment and [ __ ] and if you want
to build muscle you do need to eat more
protein no matter what anyone says every
bodybuilder in history of forever has
eaten more protein
what's the diet like the Wolverine diet
The Wolverine diet is strict it's about
4,000 calories a day maybe four and a
half as I'm bulking up and then it gets
dropped as I'm leaning up drops down to
about three three and a half thousand
calories not the fun calories this is
the
chicken fish maybe steak and it was a
couple hours a day and it was brutal
the tricky part was eating eating
everything sounds awful
see you sound nice but it's not just
like cheeseburgers you mean you have to
eat like these just bland naked pieces
of chicken and rice and it's it's not
that appetizer it was the the workout
was probably more difficult than actual
filming it was my body doesn't sit
naturally at that that white you know so
I was consuming many many calories and
protein I mean I'm being the main one
today we are going to eat like Hercules
what is this gonna consist of sir
it's gonna consist of seven whole meals
I think two steak meals there's gonna be
two fish meals two chicken meals there's
also going to be there's gonna be a
protein drink and here's the key
here's the key lion blood every athlete
eats protein you know it is what you
need to do they say gram protein per
pound of muscle that's a very arbitrary
number it's going to vary slightly
depending on you but yes you need to
increase your protein like I said watch
any interview with any celebrities in
any decent kind of shape and they'll
tell you they ate just a ton of chicken
like I said fat isn't so bad it's
nutritious and it is slow releasing
energy
so doesn't have to be lean and actually
red meat full of really great stuff
they're full of coenzyme q10 creatine
those are the things we take as
bodybuilding supplement so eat steak
again all the bodybuilders ate steak
back in the you know Golden Age of
bodybuilding 98 tons of steak usually
loads of chicken and protein shake is
protein shake as good as actual protein
from your diet
no but it's cheaper and it's more
convenient and also this one my current
favorite PhD synergy I so seven has a
very catchy name there it seems to be
catching on a lot in terms of you know
you see it a lot in shops at the moment
this is a good one not only does it
contain a lot of protein per serving
which I can't find but I know it's over
30 grams yeah not only that that
contains all sorts of vital vitamins and
minerals
it's got magnesium in there and zinc
which are both supportive for
testosterone in
the creatine creatine is great and like
so you can get it from the diet but you
can't get enough from your diet and you
can take as a set of supplement which is
probably better but I never get around
to doing it anymore
so that's quite a good all-in-one
protein shake that I like and I do use
that not necessary if you're going to
eat enough chicken etc but good more
protein more muscle so then we've got
the Xtreme paleo crowd and some other
people you know gluten-free crowd saying
word but you can't eat bread you're
saying just Karen eating bread and rice
you're going to be brain fogged well ok
for starters gluten intolerance is only
an issue for people with a gluten
intolerance that's what the science
things to say anyways more people have
maybe a gluten intolerance than we
thought and it might be something do it
odd naps I can't remember the exact
science but the point is most people are
fine eating bread I've heard people say
you shouldn't drink milk as well because
it'll give you brain fog and 50% of the
world you know have some kind of
reaction to it or some nonsense pointers
again all these athletes
they've all been eating bread they've
all been drinking milk so as all the
celebrities you know in the past that
you thought had great shape so did all
the old-time strongmen pointers maybe
you know there's some tiny benefit from
doing this but the amount of effort
you'd have to do to avoid it when we
know that you can do perfectly fine on a
much more simple and straightforward
diet you know I personally it's not
worth it to me you can worry about all
that if you're really serious about it
you probably just going to confuse
yourself and give up or you know not to
judge your ability to diet but I think
that for our people these sorts of
things are just an excuse not to just
diet normally eat less reduce your carbs
in particular but not completely and eat
more protein if you want to build muscle
it really is that simple
don't mess around with bread and milk
and confusing stuff like that what I
will say though is the absolutely must
be eating a nutrient-dense diet if you
eat a nutrient-dense diet that means
basically getting all your vitamins and
minerals from fruit vegetables proteins
you know you want to be getting your
magnesium your zinc your vitamin C your
B complex vitamins you want to be
getting omega-3 fatty acids coenzyme q10
you want to be getting bitumen
d vitamin E vitamin D you Medigap in the
summer you can't scale it from eggs you
know no you wanted to get in tryptophan
you want to be getting biotin you want
to be getting lutein you want to be
getting everything you can get from your
diet because all of these things have
amazing benefits and later people
suffering with all these individual
minerals and vitamins and I eat it for a
while but the point is they're all in
your diet you absorb them better if you
get them in your food and you know it's
tastier as well apart from anything else
often our food cravings are actually
cravings for specific nutrient
deficiencies you can get a big disease
called pica where you end up eating
gravel for instance because you have a
calcium deficiency and calcium can
increase the contractions yeah that's
going to drastically improve your
performance in the gym so the eating
your greens you know I am increases your
energy coenzyme q10 increases your
energy and your brainpower your amino
acids that you get from proteins and
protein shakes even there what your
neurotransmitters are made of they put
you in a better mood they make you
better able to focus you sleep better
you recover better everything is better
if you're getting all your nutrients and
vitamins and have fewer cravings and
you'll be fuller all the time so do make
sure that you're chasing after these
foods that we know are very
nutrient-dense the superfoods the fruits
the vegetables the spinach is the
seaweeds everything like that that's a
really good for you if you can add that
to your diet as a massive bonus you'll
work out better you will lose more
weight and your build more muscle see
like the people who are really serious
on the low carb diets they'll say you
know this smoothie is like the worst
thing you can do because it's probably
full of natural sugars but at the same
time it's just you know full of is three
fast apples too much bananas 16 grapes
3 crushed strawberries 60 crushed black
currants half a squeezed orange 9 fresh
blackberries a dash of squeezed lime
that's like all your different
bodybuilding supplements all squeezed
into one delicious juice and so many a
little bit of extra sugar you're gonna
get from that is not the end of the
world compared to all of the amazing
benefits are gonna get from it and you
know I started drinking at least the
smoothie a day as well as eating far
more fruit and veg and I haven't noticed
to have any negative impact on my shape
again we were designed to eat these
sorts of things and for the Paleo crowd
they'll probably tell you I haven't
looked into
you want Freitas but you know this with
we evolved to thrive on the food that
was available to us not the other way
around
that's why eating a natural diet is very
good for you it's just a take some time
take a little bit far by worrying too
much about wheats and all these other
things which you know probably fine
eating more vitamins and minerals it can
literally help you reverse injuries and
route disorders and sleep problems and
everything so just seek it out that's
what I say and make sure that you're
eating more of that kind of thing so and
what make maybe you used to have a pion
allotted chip some zones because that's
what I used to have and then instead of
a pile of loaded chips try having a
steak still delicious and still healthy
and instead of the chips have like a
salad or some veg and keep this portion
relatively small you actually stay
satiated full throughout the day because
of the nutrient density and you'll get
way more benefits and you lose weight
and you're build muscle you know I
understand better easy straight forwards
if you think about how it would have
been in the wild imogen you would have
been the person who was effective and
healthier would have managed to track
down more prey and find more fruit and
they'd have left got even more fit and
even more healthy it was a bit like an
RPG so you can think of it as being like
you know potassium so there you go
that's what I think is diet demystified
the way I do it like I say I fit it into
my routine is that in the morning
I just have a nice bowl of you know I
don't eat breakfast with some raisins
and nuts and things in it then I will go
to the gym I come home and have a
protein shake and or chicken then a
lunch I have a salad from the salad bar
which is great I'll get it from
Morrison's and cost me like under two
pounds and I have four eggs in there a
bunch of salad leaves tomatoes and
peppers and that sort of thing I have a
coffee in the morning and in the
afternoon I have a fruit smoothie
then I come home and I normally have
maybe another snack maybe a piece of
chicken then we'll eat dinner that would
be something like a steak and some veg
and then an evening we do have a dessert
because you know you need to dessert
sometimes and then we'll often have also
some kind of portion of additional for
like blueberries or strawberries or
something like that how do you fit all
this into your diet
that's entirely up to you but here's the
point you want to lose weight eat a
little bit less and especially less of
the simple carbs get rid of all the
taking sugars and things you know about
you it's not that complicated if you
want to build muscle eat more protein
choose a low lean protein if you're
looking for lean muscle but they were
worried too much about facts it's very
nutritious and saturated fats are good
for us even though their calorific and
nature you're generally getting a
nutrient-dense diet so that you're not
hungry
and so that you have all these other
health benefits that make you feel more
energetic getting the gym more often and
make you less likely to be over trained
so there you go pretty simple no need to
starve yourself at weird times no need
to cut entire food groups out of your
diet no need to avoid wheat and milks
just eat as you are put a little bit
healthier but you knew that really
didn't you it's like a sake please pick
four words that's my take on it so hope
you found that helpful thanks for
watching if you have any views or
comments you'd like to add please put
them in the comments below if you did
enjoy it please like share subscribe and
I will see you in the next one thanks
for watching and bye for now